in many ways the octopus is as close to
alien life as we may ever see
few creatures in the world are as
remarkable and bizarre a part of a class
of animals called cephalopods they are
among the most intelligent and most
mobile of all the invertebrates
they live in every ocean in the world
in the deep sea
in kelp forests in coral reefs along
rocky shorelines and they are as diverse
as the habitats they live in
they can be massive or absolutely tiny
some species are venomous and some are
just downright strange
in any given moment they can appear
spiky or they can appear smooth
they are so different from us that most
of their 500 million neurons are not in
their brain but in their arms which can
smell and taste and even think
and so intelligent that their cognitive
ability matches that of many large brain
vertebrates
they have left scientists stunned about
how a creature so far from us on the
evolutionary tree could evolve such
complex behaviors their intelligence
emerging in an entirely novel and
independent way from our own
so how did the octopus become so
biologically complicated an island of
complexity in the sea of invertebrate
animals just how intelligent are they
and how can studying them reveal
information about our own minds
[Music]
cephalopods have been around for a long
time fossil records show that they
evolved over 500 million years ago long
before any fish reptiles or mammals ever
appeared on earth
the early ancestor of the octopus was
quite small and had a shell which it
used to protect itself as it crawled
along the ocean bottom
cephalopods are after all members of the
mollusk phylum a group of creatures that
are usually slow and simple with soft
bodies and a hard protective shell like
snails clams and oysters but around 140
million years ago the lineage that
produced the octopus lost their shells
making them nimble agile creatures but
in the process also made them rather
vulnerable
survival of these soft-bodied creatures
for so many millions of years therefore
seems unlikely in a sea full of
dangerous hungry predators
but this vulnerability and selective
pressure may be precisely what has
allowed the octopus to become the
remarkable creature we know today
because an octopus has almost no hard
parts at all except its beak it can
squeeze through any hole as long as it's
larger than its eyeball
this allows the octopus to hide in very
small crevices a certain evolutionary
advantage when escaping large predators
like sharks or dolphins
but the soft-bodied octopus evolved an
even more clever way of evading
detection
they are masters of disguise
watching this clip of an octopus you can
see just how quickly and drastically it
can change colors
in slow motion reverse you see the color
change spread across its body
the 3d texture of the skin also changes
to match the surrounding seaweed and
coral
in the blink of an eye it has almost
completely blended in with its
surroundings
cephalopod camouflage is among the most
dynamic in the animal kingdom and relies
on a system of extremely sophisticated
tissues
chromatophores are organs that are
speckled across the skin of the octopus
like freckles they contain tiny
pigment-filled sacks like little
balloons full of different colored dye
which can be black red or yellow
the pigment sacks are surrounded by
radial muscles which can stretch the sac
to reveal the pigment's color
just like balloons full of dye when
stretched their pigment color appears
bright and vibrant
depending on which sets of sacks an
octopus opens or closes it can produce
patterns such as bands stripes or spots
helping to turn itself into a rock a
coral or a kelp in an instant
but if the octopus needs to produce
colors outside of black red and yellow
it uses another layer of reflective
structures in their skin called
erytophorse
they are stacks of very thin cells that
lay beneath the chromatophores they
contain a protein called reflectin that
bounces certain wavelengths of light
back out
they are responsible for the metallic
blues and greens that appear to shimmer
on the skin of the octopus
beneath that layer is yet another layer
of reflective tissue called lucifers
these reflect ambient light usually
producing white hues
by combining reflection from the
erytophores and lucifers with the
correct patterning of the chromatophores
the octopus can create a very convincing
copy of its surroundings
but the octopus has one more trick up
its sleeve allowing it to disappear in
plain sight almost completely
using a structure called papillae it can
change the texture of its skin creating
ridges and bumps that rise and fall
this helps the octopus match its
surroundings even better
with all these tools the shell-free
soft-bodied octopus has been able to
deceive an ocean full of predators for
millions of years
but their survival has not hinged on
these camouflage properties alone
it's the way they're controlled that is
perhaps an even more compelling survival
tool
[Music]
when an octopus travels along the sea
floor they have to assess the background
and modify their camouflage constantly
they are making decisions at a rapid
pace
one researcher observed an octopus
changing its camouflage
177 times in one hour
octopuses camouflage reaction times are
faster than any other animals up to 200
milliseconds as fast as the fastest
blink you can do
but despite doing so much with color the
octopus and almost all cephalopods are
surprisingly thought to be colorblind
how can they match colors they can't
even see
in 2015 the answer to this question
started to be uncovered researchers
found that the skin of an octopus is
sensitive to light due to photoreceptor
genes active in the skin
even when the skin was detached from the
body it could respond to light and
change the shape of its chromatophores
scientists realize that an octopus can
see with not just its eyes but also its
skin
but as the octopus body was evolving its
color-changing defense mechanisms when
it lost its shell 140 million years ago
another transformation occurred the
development of its large brain and
nervous system
the photoreceptor genes in the skin work
in connection with the octopus's large
and complex brain
the octopus can change colors so fast
because the octopus controls its
chromatophores neurally
other animals that can change color like
chameleons for example take much longer
because their color change is hormonally
controlled
hormones take time to get into the blood
and distribute around the body
a color change can take over 20 seconds
when controlled this way
some researchers believe that color
change in the octopus may be like
breathing or blinking for us something
it can choose to do but also something
that can happen involuntarily it can
have awareness from its eyes and brain
but also throughout its body
the octopus nervous system is large like
ours but built with a different
relationship between body and brain
altogether
the common octopus has around half a
billion neurons in its body for
comparison humans have about a hundred
billion
most invertebrates usually have much
less
snails have only twenty thousand
but cephalopods like the octopus score
in the same range as many vertebrates
like cats dogs and parrots more than any
other invertebrate and of their 500
million neurons only a third are found
in their brain
the majority are found in their eight
arms
and as strange as it sounds this allows
the octopus to in a way think with its
arms for a long time scientists have
known that a severed octopus arm can
respond to stimuli an hour after being
separated from the central brain but a
paper last year began to reveal the
extent of this autonomy using video
modeling they observed the octopus as it
explored objects in its tank and looked
for food the program quantified
movements of the arms tracking how the
arms work together in synchrony
suggesting direction from the brain or
asynchronously suggesting independent
decision making in each appendage
and they found that in the flow of
information from the environment to the
octopus some information bypasses the
central brain
entirely the suckers in arms can in a
way think for themselves allowing the
octopus to analyze its environment
extremely quickly and react with
matching speed
along with skin that can perceive and
change color on its own the relationship
between brain and body in the octopus is
full of blurred lines
and on top of this unusual neural layout
and strange body autonomy cephalopods
are smart extremely smart and this is
really what gives the octopus its
alien-like status
they are so far from any other
intelligent life on the tree of
evolution but still compete with
vertebrates in their raw cognitive
ability
evolution invented intelligent life not
once but twice in two completely
different ways
in the evolutionary tree of life we sit
upon the branch of mammals nearby are
the fish reptiles birds and amphibians
the other members of the larger
classification of vertebrates this group
is where we see all of the intelligent
life we normally think of
humans primates dogs cats dolphins and
some birds when we collect these animals
and trace back to our common ancestor it
was likely a lizard-like animal that
lived around 320 million years ago
like us this animal would have had a
backbone four limbs a head and a
skeleton it would have walked around
well adapted to land and had a
well-developed central nervous system
but to find where we split from the
octopus we have to travel much further
down the branches to around 600 million
years ago the creature we find there is
a simple flat worm it had an extremely
basic nervous system and no inklings of
what we would consider intelligence
as the evolutionary tree branched and
diverged intelligence blossomed on our
branch of vertebrates and totally
separately in the cephalopods
and with the cephalopods evolving before
any of the intelligent vertebrates it's
likely that they were the first
intelligent animals that appeared on
earth
but what actually is intelligence how
can we identify or even measure such a
thing in an animal so different from us
in humans intelligence is commonly
defined as the ability to think
abstractly understand communicate
problem solve learn form memories and
plan actions
this is usually measured by intelligence
tests which can be given a numerical
value
but we can't give a standardized test to
an octopus we can only observe their
behaviors
why the cephalopods well they're the
most interesting mollusks in terms of
behavior no question to learn more about
the depth of octopus intelligence as
researchers currently understand it i
spoke with jennifer mather professor in
the department of psychology at
university of lethbridge and scientific
advisor for the film my octopus teacher
pretty well every learning task you give
them they can do
short-term long-term spatial memory
object perception you know
but it's more than learning
they also go in for planning
and planning is not so obvious
and one of the famous examples is what
that's been called the coconut carrying
octopus so the octopus is going off to a
place where there's no shelter
and it takes these coconut halves with
them and when it wants to stop and rest
it picks them up and brings them up
because it's like they're surrounded
it's amazing
some scientists argue that this behavior
is a rare example of composite tool use
a behavior previously thought to only
exist in humans some primates and some
birds and it may be evidence of complex
intelligence for two reasons
first this tool use might represent a
behavioral innovation allowing octopuses
to protect themselves in areas where
they can't otherwise hide
second because the coconut shells are
transported with great effort to meet
future needs this behavior might
indicate an octopus's planning ability
the octopus has to imagine the future
and connect the dots between past events
current actions and future events which
is not a simple task
octopuses also do well in memory tests
and can differentiate between different
people even when they're wearing the
same outfit
and in a study done by professor mather
the common octopus has also been shown
to be extremely playful
i would describe them as extremely
exploratory sort of like a five-year-old
kid
taking stuff apart
going off and feeling around with the
landscape
just grabbing more information
play is often defined as a behavior that
is not necessary for survival done on
purpose but seemingly for pleasure the
action is often repeated exaggerated and
carried out when the animal is
adequately fed healthy and not under
stress
we figured that
the animals were more likely to play if
they were safe and bored so we set up
octopuses in an aquarium with a place to
hide
and nothing else
and then we got a pill bottle and put
enough water in it that it floated at
the surface
also in the mix was a water intake pump
for the aquarium that the researchers
hadn't necessarily intended to be part
of the experiment it created a current
that pushed the pill bottle across the
top of the tank which sparked the
curiosity of some of the octopuses
so we did this with six animals okay
in two cases
the pill bottle came across like this
the octopus shot a jet of water at it
which
meant that it went back towards the
water intake and it came back again if
an octopus did this once or even twice
it wouldn't be experimentally
significant but a few carried out this
behavior so many times that it couldn't
be ignored
one of them did this i think it was 14
times and one of them did it 21 times it
was the marine equivalent of bouncing
the ball
in addition to helping establish motor
coordination play in most species is
largely needed for social purposes for
establishing rank for learning social
rules or for social bonding and due to
its complexity play is considered to be
almost exclusive to mammals with a few
exceptions and other vertebrates like
some birds
but the octopus is a solitary creature
it has no social bonds no social
hierarchy it makes us rethink the
evolutionary reasons for play
in fact much of our idea of intelligence
is based on the idea that it evolved out
of a social need for decades scientists
have wondered about the origins of
intelligence and have tried to
understand why certain animals evolved
intelligence and others did not
the social intelligence hypothesis is
the often favored hypothesis for the
evolution of complex cognition
it's the idea that intelligence evolved
due to the demands of group living such
as maintaining complex and enduring
social bonds deception cooperation or
social learning
when most of the animals we think of as
smart humans primates dogs dolphins
began living in groups there became a
need for more complex behaviors and
therefore a bigger more complex brain
but this theory can't explain why
intelligence evolved in cephalopods
a different theory must exist for these
non-social creatures
you see our big problem with knowing the
development of intelligence is that we
know it
from the mammals from the primates
our relatives
so we know that this particular set of
conditions sets us up for being
intelligent
but then if we have another model
the octopus then we have to say okay
these conditions being part of a social
group they're not necessary for
intelligence
perhaps the pressures of finding food
and evading predation is enough for
intelligence to blossom
this is the basis for the ecological
intelligence hypothesis
which suggests that complex cognition
evolved to meet the challenges
associated with predation foraging and
competitive pressures
and when the octopus lost its shell 140
million years ago perhaps the pressure
of predation was so high that
outsmarting their attackers became the
only way for it to survive
these two theories are not competing
ones but rather two explanations for two
instances of intelligence on the tree of
life
the octopus gives us a rare chance to
investigate an alternate intelligence an
alien-like life-form here on earth
where we once thought there was only one
model for intelligence we now know there
are at least two and who's to say how
many more there could be on this earth
or elsewhere
but despite the distance from us on the
evolutionary tree the octopus still
lives inside the same grand experiment
as we do
the earth the oceans and the spinning
wheels of evolution have crafted us both
they are not so much alien then as much
as a distant distant relative and by
stepping aside from our human-centric
view of intelligence can we start to
clearly see the infinite possibilities
of cognition
the story of the modern octopus began so
long ago
back when there was no life yet on land
but around this time 500 million years
ago the oceans had begun to explode with
life
this period called the ordovician was
known for its amazing diversity of
invertebrates and of these invertebrates
the massive armored cephalopods were
king they dominated the seas for roughly
360 million years the fossil records
show an amazing array of creatures
during this time some we recognize and
some we definitely don't
life was thriving until something
stopped nearly all of it in its tracks
to learn more about this period on the
early earth and understand what nearly
wiped out all of the animals in the
planet's first mass extinction you
should watch ancient oceans on curiosity
stream it's a two-part series that
covers the ordovician and devonian
periods and explores the boom of animals
then and the subsequent mass extinctions
curiosity stream is a streaming platform
with thousands of high quality
documentaries like this one and now
curiosity stream has partnered with us
to offer an incredible deal by signing
up to curiositystream you now also get a
subscription to nebula nebula is a
streaming platform made by me and
several other educational youtube
content creators it's a place where we
can upload our videos ad free and a
place where we can experiment with new
original content
by signing up to the bundle deal you'll
get access to both curiosity stream and
nebula and you'll be just in time to
catch real engineering's final episode
of the nebula original series the
logistics of d-day about the red ball
express
the logistics of d-day is a nine-part
mini-series that covers the engineering
and tactical advantages that the allies
use to achieve victory when invading
german occupied france and it's
exclusive to nebula so by signing up at
curiositystream.com
real science you'll get a subscription
to curiosity stream and a subscription
to nebula for just 14.79 for the entire
year
signing up is also the best way to
support this channel and all of your
favorite educational content creators
thanks for watching and if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
instagram twitter and patreon are below
[Music]
[Music]
you